we need one million dollars and if you
give us one million dollars we will
generate you a money machine that lasts
for all the time I take out a napkin and
a pen I say here is our business plan
dollar sign Arrow Facebook Arrow website
Arrow back to dollar sign this is our
business plan they fired Jeremy the next
day we have two choices at this point
Choice number one is we mortgage our
houses and just do the idea ourselves
and this was in retrospect what we
probably should have done yeah at the
time we find a family office and we
pitch this family office on exactly this
plan and this guy at the end of the
table turns to me and says we get a lot
of pitches on media companies just like
this one what makes you think you're so
special and I was like I'm better at
this than anyone on the planet everyone
who's pitched you is worse at this than
I am
and for a second there was like dead
silence in the room and then everybody
started laughing and they put the money
into the company and the initial amount
of money they put into the company was
4.8 million dollars we did 200 million
dollars in Revenue last year what do you
think that original investment is worth
today well into the nine figures
unbelievable